boomers are going to retire this is real
the boomers are going to retire now they
don't want to they don't want to and we
have some articles we'll talk about
later in the show where the Boomers
actually don't want the world to
continue a friend of mine sent me this
border thing this is so hilarious over
Instagram and was basically like what a
and the she sent me this article like
are we going to have a civil war and she
goes what an exciting time to
alive they are giddy at the prospect of
the entire American experiment failing
and the uh civilization going dark
boomers are bullant at the they are
sitting around pubs and Casual
restaurants and they are sitting at
country clubs and they are actually very
excited about the prospect of
civilization crumbling because they are
at the end of their life the Boomers
never wanted their children to have
better lives than they did ever the
Boomers were threatened by their
children the Boomers viewed their
children as obstacles to their own
success and
fulfillment this is all in the book
coming out I know you don't think it's
coming out I don't care what you think
it's coming out it'll be there in the
summer you read it on a beach but this
is all true and the more I observe these
Boomers which I have for my entire life
and I'm really keying in on it
now what I'm noticing is that they're
kind of a death cult the boomers are a
death cult in the way that radical Islam
is a death
cult radical Islam doesn't really have
an interest in anybody existing that
isn't a a a devotee of the of what they
think and what they believe Boomers in
the exact same way they are ready to
usher in the apocalypse and they're
doing it gleefully they're holding on
all the houses and all the money you
know we have an article here
80% of the stock market
80% of the stock market is owned by
elderly people
Boomers they can sell it and trigger a
downturn here we go your grandma is a
downside risk to the stock market how
more old people owning equities could
exacerbate a downt the boomers are
holding the American economy
hostage they're holding it hostage and
they can at any
time flood the market by selling all
their stock taking all the
cash now many people go well they're
going to take it from medical
emergencies and they're GNA take they're
going to take the cash and whatever
they're going to do with it okay they're
going to like fund some nightmarish
thing it's like Pinky in the brain with
these people like they're going to take
the cash out of the stock market so they
can build a laser to zap the world the
way that they are going on now refusing
to sell these mcmansions they will not
downsize they will not give up their
jobs Biden will not step aside he's 80
80 he's an octogenarian he's elderly he
doesn't he's he's foaming at the mouth
he's got dementia and and he will not
step aside who's that that just died in
office was it Feinstein mhm they die in
office now these senators and Cong one
article I read one the Pentagon by the
way prepare to report this is go true
the Pentagon is prepared to report now
one of the threats they talk about bio
weapons they're talking about covid uh
it's on drudge this is a new thing they
wrote about how like you know here's the
threat uh threats that we
anticipate okay here are the threats
that we we anticipate coming one of the
threats okay is this is great A new
study by the office of the Secretary of
Defense provides a unique window into
the views of military planners and how
they see future forms of
warfare so now we know covid we go da d
d da we got Co so here if you go up so I
love this
okay
additionally listen to this okay
additionally the author's caution
against the possibility of government
employees replacing their natural ey
lenses with artificial ones containing
tiny cameras connected to micro storage
devices the small cameras could collect
classified intelligence and leak it to
foreign adversaries okay now the reason
that they're worried about this by the
way come up go up a little bit
here they're talking about in another
intriguing scenario seemingly inspired
by the decline of Senator Diane
Feinstein and this time set in a more
distant future the report suggests that
elderly Congressional leaders desperate
to retain power this is everything I've
ever said it's in the this report that
the Pentagon has now just come out the
Pentagon is saying the biggest threat to
the body politic to the survival of our
country is not climate change it's not
for all its other issues immigration it
is Boomer
Boomers will
not relinquish power listen to this is
actually really fascinating in another
intriguing scenario seemingly inspired
by the decline of Senator Diane
Feinstein and this time set in a more
distant future and by the way they mean
like five years from now the report
suggests that elderly Congressional
leaders desperate to retain power
secretly install state-of-the-art brain
computer interface devices these devices
is commonly used among wealthy senior
citizens in this scenario initially
helped the Senators regain mobility and
speech after years of clear cognitive
decline this by the way is the wildest
report I have read in a long time I read
these things so you don't have to I sift
through them I work hard to take these
private planes you don't think I do many
of you don't think I do